[Música]
se cumple un año desde que el presidente
de El Salvador nayib bukele convocó a la
asamblea legislativa de ese país para
que votara a favor de un decreto de
emergencia que estaría vigente por 30
días la idea de este proyecto era
reducir la violencia a nivel nacional
que está relacionada con las pandillas
desde entonces el estado de excepción ha
sido extendido en 12 oportunidades esto
implica la suspensión de garantías
constitucionales y según reportan
algunos organismos y algunas ong ha
habido abusos contra los Derechos
Humanos por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad de ese país centroamericano
más detalles de lo que sucede en el
Salvador en el siguiente reporte que
preparó la redacción de France 24 veamos
[Música]
el país donde la seguridad y el temor
convergen los salvadoreños cumplen un
año desde el inicio de la guerra contra
las pandillas muchos de los habitantes
celebran mejores condiciones de
seguridad en sus calles
una vida de otra mejor que esa la
seguridad que está hoy porque
anteriormente
era difícil sobrevivir
salía uno no sabía si volvía a llegar a
regresar a la casa otra vez fue el 27 de
marzo del 2022 cuando el gobierno
estableció un régimen de excepción como
respuesta a 87 homicidios perpetrados
durante tres días y aunque la versión
oficial es el combate el crimen
organizado medios locales revelaron que
la violencia fue el resultado de la
ruptura de un pacto secreto entre el
gobierno y las pandillas según cifras
oficiales la medida ha dejado más de
60.000 pandilleros detenidos pero
organismos locales reportan más de 3.000
detenciones arbitrarias incluso
denuncian que 72 personas murieron en
custodia del Estado hay jóvenes que
están en las cárceles que no están sin
hacer nada sin haber cometido un delito
Simplemente porque iban en las calles
porque le cayó mal al policía al soldado
se lo llevaron
amnistía internacional y otros
organismos critican los métodos del
presidente nayib bukele cuya campaña de
seguridad le da puntos en las encuestas
Pero dentro de las presiones algunos
funcionarios creen que las pandillas no
están desarticuladas y que podrían
actuar en venganza en cualquier momento
de estos 60 a 66.000 personas que han
sido detenidas cerca del 90% de los
casos las personas han sido detenidos
por periodos prolongados en prisión
provisional y no han tenido oportunidad
para que un juez conozca cada uno de los
casos la llegada masiva de personas
detenidas también ha provocado que El
Salvador sea hoy en día el país con la
tasa de encarcelamiento más alta del
mundo también recordemos un hecho que no
es menor en la apertura de esa mega
cárcel llamada el centro de
confinamiento del terrorismo las
acciones las cifras el de proceder a
convertido esta medida de emergencia que
era temporal en toda una estrategia de
seguridad que ante los ojos de muchos
ciudadanos funciona las cifras de
disminución de la violencia así lo
respaldan pero otros tienen otro factor
para analizar por ejemplo el alto costo
las violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
las denuncias de hacinamiento y también
el maltrato a los detenidos entre otros
aspectos la estrategia comienza también
a ganar no solamente dentro del Salvador
sino que también muchos sectores
políticos y sociales de otros países de
la región han comenzado a mirar en
detalle con lupa esta rigurosa medida
para ver su posible instauración en
otros países entendiendo que la
inseguridad y la violencia en general
son un problema que aqueja a
prácticamente todos los países de
América Latina y que no ha habido ni un
gobierno de derecha o de izquierda
dictadura o democracia que lo haya
podido combatir de manera efectiva es la
estrategia del Salvador entonces la
fórmula para combatir la inseguridad
Pero a qué costo Ya lo vamos a ver en
este caso en particular un año después
de haber sido instaurado el estado de
excepción en El Salvador hoy en el
debate de France 24 lo analizamos sus
pros sus contras Y cómo la estrategia ha
significado un imbatible liderazgo en
los índices de popularidad como decía el
reportaje del presidente nayib bukele
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Eva
lardizábal ella es directora del centro
ars para América Latina del Atlántico
cónsul ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
Washington en los Estados Unidos desde
San Salvador la capital del Salvador se
conecta Abraham abrego Él es director de
litigio estratégico de la ong Cristóbal
y también me acompañan el estudio de
France 24 Carlos Andrés Arias él es
docente de la maestría de comunicación
política de la Universidad externado de
Colombia él se encuentra aquí con
nosotros en el estudio de France 24 en
la capital colombiana nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate ustedes ya lo sabe puede dejar
sus comentarios y todas sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook también en instagram
no se encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24
todo pegado todo junto y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa también
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Eva en la ciudad de Washington Eva
Gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
el programa en el debate de France 24 y
Punto de partida para esta discusión el
balance que hace usted de este año de
estado de excepción en El Salvador y
esta estrategia para disminuir los
índices de inseguridad en El Salvador
bienvenida
bueno Muchas gracias Santiago por la
invitación al programa es un placer y un
saludo especial a todos los televidentes
Bueno desde mi punto de vista y cómo la
estamos viendo ahorita en Washington DC
hay Bueno estamos viendo en un punto
global todas las personas donde estamos
acostumbrados a digerir la información y
leer las noticias a la velocidad de la
luz y este mismo sentimiento se ve en la
política uno cuando como presidente
entra a al poder teniendo cuatro cinco
seis años para lograr las metas de
política que uno ASUME y uno promete
cuando se se pone se postulan y nayib
bukele entró al poder con un grave
problema un alto índice de de homicidios
que estaban como al
36% el 36 mil habitantes y teniendo
cuatro cinco seis años en su caso cinco
años para reducir ese problema
resolvió a implementar políticas a corto
plazo en este caso políticas de mano
dura unas que no son sostenibles e
históricamente no han sido sostenibles
bueno qué pasa con estas políticas de
mano dura facilitan las violaciones de
los Derechos Humanos como usted lo dijo
y van en el detrimento de la Democracia
pero son efectivas en reducir el
homicidio sí sin embargo no piensan qué
va a pasar a los cinco diez quince
veinte años de cuando ya no está en el
poder Entonces es una manera de poder
ver a largo plazo Cómo se puede
solucionar este problema
Punto de partida de nuestra invitada en
la ciudad de Washington pasó a darle la
palabra a Abraham en la ciudad de San
Salvador
su opinión sobre el balance que usted
hace de este año de excepción de lo que
ha significado esto para la de mocracia
salvadoreña y los resultados que esta
política de seguridad si se le puede
llamar así ha tenido para el presidente
bukele bienvenido
gracias Muy buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación
nosotros valoramos Este primer año de
régimen de excepción con un balance
negativo
creemos que se suma al retroceso de la
institucionalidad democrática que venía
teniendo el gobierno del presidente
bukele y sobre todo porque ha generado
un miles de violaciones de derechos
humanos y sobre todo una práctica
de desmontaje de las garantías
judiciales que ha hecho que en El
Salvador prácticamente ahora la
detención sea hecha con arbitrariedad y
sin control judicial Y esta es una
herramienta que nuestro temor es que no
se ha usado solo en el momento ahora que
se está hablando del combate de las
pandillas sino que como ha demostrado
también el registro causado como un
instrumento de represión y de político
prácticamente no solo es el régimen sino
que hay que recordar que en este año
también ha habido un conjunto bastante
acelerado de reformas legales tan vuelto
permanente algunas de las prácticas que
hemos vivido en el régimen entonces en
términos generales el costo
para la sociedad salvadoreña que va a
tener régimen es sumamente grave y yo
cuestiono que el régimen sea el que
podemos decir que
es la reducción la criminalidad de las
pandillas sí Y aquí en el estudio de
France 24 para terminar esta primera
ronda Carlos Andrés bienvenido un gusto
tenerlo acá en el programa su opinión de
este primer año a mí me parece que que
el análisis tiene que partir desde donde
usted hace la pregunta y es la
democracia yo no creo que pueda existir
democracia cuando hay violaciones
flagrantes a los derechos humanos y al
derecho internacional humanitario
entonces efectivamente Y concuerdo con
Eva que que la medida de bukele reduce
el número de homicidios reduce la
violencia en las calles reduce la
violencia urbana Incluso perimetral en
algunas áreas de diferentes capitales en
en en el país sin embargo yo creo que no
se puede hacer un balance positivo de la
democracia en Salvador y tiene que haber
un análisis posterior seguramente en el
siguiente segmento de lo que impacta en
la región y lo que impacta en la
percepción no solamente de los
habitantes sino de todo el continente y
para cerrar mi observación sobre este
primer punto yo creo que más allá de los
efectos democráticos es un efecto social
que va a derivar en otras generaciones
en resentimientos que no hemos visto
todavía los resentimientos de los hijos
de los hermanos de esas personas que han
sido capturadas quizás sin pruebas
quizás siempre pruebas esas pensando un
poco a futuro lo vamos a analizar lo
tengo dentro de la agenda Carlos Andrés
hago la ronda la inversa le pregunto
ahora Abraham Quiero llevar esto de
adentro hacia afuera Aparentemente las
cifras acompañan esta política digámoslo
de seguridad que instaurado el
presidente bukele Cuál es la percepción
para el salvadoreño de a pie en el día a
día en sus actividades cotidianas se
siente
una por lo menos en la capital en San
Salvador se siente una ciudad mucho más
segura ustedes van más tranquilos por la
calle Abraham
efectivamente hay una percepción de la
población sobre todo en territorio donde
Antes había un control fuerte de las
pandillas de una percepción de mayor
seguridad
Entonces si efectivamente eso se está
dando en algunas zonas
Pero eso no quiere decir porque nosotros
que llevamos por ejemplo casos de
desplazamiento forzado que haya
disminuido en otros territorios la la
intervención de pandillas por ejemplo en
este periodo Nosotros hemos identificado
400 personas que sean desplazado por
violencia en su mayoría son de pandillas
pero
un dato importante es que ha aumentado
la gente que se desplaza ya no por razón
de las pandillas sino que por razón de
la policía o los militares debido a
cosas policial o abusos de Derechos
Humanos entonces hay una percepción de
seguridad de la población
porque visiblemente hay un retroceso en
la actividad del pandillas pero
ojo que creo que hay que esperar todavía
un tiempo
sobre cómo se puede reconvertir este
fenómeno criminal y hay que decir que
todavía hay problemas de violencia en El
Salvador claro la violencia no se ha
terminado por completo hay una reducción
y Justo eso me lleva a hacerle a Eva la
pregunta si estas cifras que presenta el
gobierno que se volvió prácticamente su
tema abanderado de logro de gestión ha
sido esta reducción de el índice de
criminalidad sobre todo por ese repunte
que hubo un par de años atrás se puede
confiar en estas cifras se puede confiar
en los reportes que hay por parte del
gobierno o esto tiene un componente de
propaganda
Bueno yo lo veo que por un lado el
gobierno puede decir lo que uno quiere
lo que ellos registran pero es parte en
responsabilidad de la comunidad
internacional de también hacer ese
seguimiento y reportar lo que pueden
dentro de la información que pueden
lograr sé que jimen Rights watch y
amnistía internacional y otras
organizaciones han hecho este tipo de
reportaje incluso Cristóbal que la
organización al cual pertenece a Abraham
Así que hay que tomarlos como decimos en
inglés
con grano de de sal pero también
ver o sea más atrás de están bajando las
tasas de domicilios este estado de
excepción es efectivamente una curita al
tema de seguridad no se están abordando
los problemas fundamentales del que
sufre El Salvador Cuáles son estos
problemas la desigualdad la informalidad
la falta de educación
la marginalización las altas tasas de
pobreza que muchas de de las áreas donde
se han visto ese estado de excepción
sufren y han emisorio históricamente han
sufrido entonces uno se pone a pensar
Bueno cuando casi el dos por ciento de
la población se encuentra encarcelada
muchos de ellos que en cualquier otra
alternativa pueden ser parte de la
fuerza laboral uno se pone a pensar en
bueno por un lado puede ser si estoy
viendo de reelegirme en el 2024 pero al
igual no hay garantías que pueda ser
elegido claro no hay garantías Carlos
aquí para terminar esta Ronda de acuerdo
a lo que dice el problema es de fondo y
aquí se está poniendo una cura sobre un
problema que es grave pero es
superficial El Salvador y no solamente
este país de Centroamérica sino buena
parte de los países de latinoamérica
trabajan poco en estos problemas de
fondo o qué opinión tiene usted Mire yo
voy a intentar parafrasear de una manera
muy coloquial y espero que la audiencia
me perdone es cuando las parejas están
peleando están casadas están peleando y
están a punto de divorciarse y suponen
que vendiendo el sofá de la sala en
donde discutían van a solucionar sus
problemas y van a seguir adelante con la
relación San Salvador está y Salvador
Digamos como como país más que como la
ciudad está está mitigando un problema
vendiendo el sofá está intentando
encarcelar a una serie de personajes que
pueden haber estado o pueden llegar a
posiblemente estar vinculados en la
violencia pero lamentablemente no está
atacando las fondos de los temas de
fondo que es desigualdad que es equidad
que se empleó que es educación que es
salud que es vivienda es decir no se le
puede decir a los a los pandilleros en
muchos en muchos lugares de nuestro
continente que el problema es que ellos
quieren estar en las pandillas per se
por sí mismos están las pandillas es
porque muchos de ellos no tienen
oportunidades de ingresar y de
insertarse en la vida social de Más allá
del ejercicio de la productividad el
llamado éxito de la productividad es
insertarse en una vida social que los
respete que les dé dignidad y por eso
acuden a este tipo de ejercicios
tribales Entonces yo creo que el gran
problema es que estamos vendiendo el
sofá Cuando verdaderamente tendríamos
que ir a una terapia de familia a una
terapia en la cual el estado salvadoreño
empiece a pensar en
soluciones de mediano y largo plazo para
reconstituir a la sociedad claro y ver
el problema de fondo hago la ronda la
inversa continúo con usted Carlos y ya
lo estamos mencionando en la
introducción y en algunos de los
comentarios que ustedes estaban haciendo
Y es el deterioro de la Democracia hay
alertas y organismos internacionales ya
lo han denunciado aquí estas alertas a
nivel internacional se emiten
simplemente para darlas a conocer o hay
un llamado de atención serio a las a las
autoridades al gobierno del presidente
bukele diciéndole está logrando usted
tener ciertos números favorables pero
pero esto está teniendo un alto costo en
la institucionalidad y en la y en la de
y ahí hasta qué punto los organismos
internacionales pueden entrar o lo dejan
simplemente A discreción de los
gobiernos salvadas las proporciones yo
creo que esto solamente puede llegar a
ser corregido puede llegarse a tener un
llamado de alerta internacional cuando
la Corte Penal Internacional entre a a a
a a a hacer una investigación de fondo y
a pronunciarse de fondo sobre este tema
y lo más lo más problemático de este
asunto no es ni siquiera que este tipo
de organismos empiecen a generar algún
tipo de hecho de facto contra el
gobierno salvadoreño Porque si las
organizaciones no gubernamentales como
human right watch o como otras para no
citar todas las que ustedes han
mencionado en el reporte siguen haciendo
denuncias pues sí son válidas pero hasta
que no tengamos un un ejercicio de fondo
de un estamento internacional no va a
pasar absolutamente nada y para mí creo
que lo más grave de esto no es no es ni
siquiera lo que está sucediendo en San
Salvador y en El Salvador sino que lo
que se está reproduciendo en otros
gobernantes de América Latina que
régimen de izquierda a derecha están
utilizando prácticas populistas Sí eso
lo vamos a hablar más adelante Este
modelo si es visto con lupa por otros
gobiernos para adaptar ciertas
características para combatir la
inseguridad le preguntó a Eva para
continuar con la ronda un poco en el en
medio del desorden le pregunto entonces
para garantizar Esa esa democracia
salvadoreña se puede confiar en la
división de poderes o ya El poder del
presidente en este momento
está abarcando las diferentes
instituciones y está ayudando en ese
desmoronamiento lento de la de los
valores democráticos
bueno efectivamente hemos estado viendo
la centralización del poder dentro de
los tres poderes del Estado del
ejecutivo legislativo y el judicial
si con esta centralización del poder uno
se pone a pensar Bueno ya la bukele
anunció que que va a dar buscar la
reelección sin embargo es contra la
Constitución y ya que eso se puede hacer
uno se pone a pensar bueno es posible
hacer cualquier cosa dentro de esa
centralización del poder
sin embargo
tanto el gobierno de bukele como a la
asamblea legislativa deben adoptar
medidas sostenibles y respetuosas de los
derechos para desmantelar las pandillas
y proteger la población de estos abusos
y esto incluyen abordar las causas
fundamentales de la violencia de las
pandillas y concuerdo con el punto de
Carlos Andrés sobre
Cómo va a surgir un resentimiento si no
se abarca dentro del poder Abraham su
opinión sobre este tema algo para añadir
mire lo que en el día Yo es que
falta una investigación sobre el rol de
funcionarios en negociaciones con
pandillas y el problema puede ser más
complejo en el sentido que si el estado
está involucrado con negociaciones en
pandillas para disminuir la criminalidad
o incluso como en otras ocasiones para
lograr réditos electorales para
presionar a votantes etcétera creo que
estamos hablando de un problema más
grave porque ya no solo es el problema
de normal que tendría un estado de
combatir la la criminalidad sino que
estaríamos hablando de
un asocio entre un grupo con grupos
criminales y el estado que los utiliza
el servicio de intereses políticos
entonces creo que también eso es un
fenómeno grave que podría resultar en
una en una mutación de lo que han sido
las pandillas en el Salvador entonces yo
creo que en la medida que se conozca más
de de la investigación Incluso en Nueva
York hay una un proceso de investigación
contra algunos pandilleros donde está ha
salido tanto la información y las
evidencias sobre involucramiento de
varios funcionarios entonces creo que es
un factor que tomar en cuenta porque
estaríamos ya con el tema retroceso
democrático también hablando de de
crímenes organizado con la anuencia del
estado
Abraham y dentro de esa estructura Y ese
retroceso democrático también hay
denuncias de otros aspectos importantes
por ejemplo
silenciar algunos opositores políticos
los medios independientes se han visto
en cierta forma perseguidos hay control
también sobre el poder judicial Ya lo
habíamos dicho en cierta forma hay
censura uno mira esto y no es que
estemos hablando de Nicaragua estamos
hablando del Salvador que supuestamente
es un es un gobierno elegido
democráticamente y que tiene unas
características y una democracia mucho
más afianzada que su vecino
centroamericano
estas denuncias infundadas esto se vive
en la realidad salvadoreña cuéntenos
Sí la verdad que hay un retroceso
bastante acelerado de garantías y
nuestro temor es que y de hecho ha
pasado que todo el andamiaje creado con
el régimen se está utilizando contra
comunidades
activistas políticos periodistas
Defensores de Derechos Humanos
organizaciones ambientales Y esa es una
expresión que estamos viendo en la
práctica pero también con reformas
legales mordazas verdad hay ahora unas
reformas legales que incluso prohíben a
los periodistas ni siquiera mencionar el
tema del control territorial de
pandillas menos incluir en su reportaje
las fotos de los logos de pandillas el
tema de la Incluso
un simple tatuaje artístico ya puede ser
sujeto de criminalización ya no se diga
reportajes o críticas Entonces yo creo
que aunque estamos viendo las
diferencias con Nicaragua El Salvador y
si no hay un cambio abrupto se está
dirigiendo prácticamente a este tipo de
prácticas de represión y de control Yo
creo que la elección del otro año del
Depende cómo quede la correlación de
fuerzas van a ser fundamentales porque
si no creo que lo que va a pasar en El
Salvador cada vez más estas prácticas
que se han dado en Nicaragua y que ya
son de represión Carlos ya teniendo más
en detalle digamos que la foto completa
que esto no solamente está afectando el
tema de la seguridad esto es un efecto
bola de nieve porque empieza a afectar
otros sectores de la política y de la y
de la vida cotidiana de los salvadoreños
Cómo explica uno que todas estas
denuncias de violaciones de derechos
humanos de retrocesos democráticos y ve
a uno el índice de popularidad que está
presentando el presidente bukele como la
sociedad salvadoreña entiende ese canje
no me importa los Derechos Humanos pero
yo prefiero seguridad al costo que sea
mire en estrategias de persuasión en
psicología social hay un modelo teórico
que es la racionalidad eficiente esa
racionalidad eficiente explica como
modelo teórico en psicología social que
los ciudadanos cognitivamente preferimos
el bienestar personal que el bienestar
como el colectivo del plural entonces Si
eso me beneficia a mí como decía Abraham
si yo puedo salir a la calle y puedo
entre comillas sentir que no me va a
pasar nada o que en las últimas semanas
a nadie en mi entorno Familiar o cercano
de amigos le ha pasado nada Yo empiezo a
sentir que de alguna otra forma esto
tiene que ver conmigo directamente y si
a mí nunca o si a mí ya me había pasado
algo sin familia mi familia había sido
víctima de algún tipo de ataque violente
o alguna de estas pandillas y veo que
durante unas semanas o dos semanas o un
mes no ha pasado nada empieza a generar
un ejercicio de elección racional
eficiente ejercicio de elección racional
eficiente sobre mi percepción No importa
la de los demás es decir no importa si
violando tratados internacionales no
importa si esto está generando un
populismo que no sé que esa medida de
entre comillas de política pública no se
puede sostener en el tiempo no importa
qué pasa con esas personas que están en
las cárceles Lo importante es que mi
vida en el día a día esté bien y ahí
Creo que el ejercicio de los medios de
comunicación de organizaciones no
gubernamentales tiene que empezar a
desarrollar una estrategia Más allá de
lo jurídico en lo comunicacional para
las a esas personas que están allí para
que entiendan la gravedad lo que están
sufriendo Más allá del día a día y la
fotografía la encuesta y que entiendan
que pueden estar metiéndose en un
callejón sin salida Eva su opinión sobre
este tema del índice de popularidad
envidiable por cualquier punto que usted
lo mire por parte de cualquier
mandatario sobre todo en la región de
América Latina Pero a qué costo
bueno efectivamente concuerdo 100% con
lo que dijo Carlos Andrés sobre cómo las
personas presiden este bienestar
personal sobre el bienestar colectivo y
regresando a mi primer punto las
personas tienen una vista a corto plazo
en vez de a largo plazo a largo plazo
exactamente uno Entra o sea bukele
entrando como presidente tiene cinco
años para resolver su tema de de altas
tasas de homicidio y va a ser lo que sea
para para reducirlo y uno como Ciudadano
ve que está rindiendo frutos hoy mismo
mañana en vez de cinco días quince años
entonces uno dice Bueno la estoy pasando
súper bien porque me tengo que preocupar
de la futura generaciones que van a
tener que vivir por una incertidumbre
porque uno no sabe si estas políticas de
estado de excepción van a seguir en diez
quince veinte años y volvemos al tema de
Qué pasa si estas políticas terminan no
hay políticas para reinserción social de
esas sesenta mil personas que están
encarceladas que se van a hacer con esas
personas entonces es un punto muy muy
importante que que tener en mente claro
puede ser un problema aún más grande el
día de mañana Abraham muchos ven esto
como una gran apuesta que está haciendo
El Salvador para mostrarse al mundo como
un país seguro para atraer la inversión
extranjera para para hacer foco a nivel
económico y político en la región de
Centroamérica y Pero esto no puede ser
una estrategia solamente ideada por un
presidente o por un gobierno de turno
aquí hay intereses internacionales de
peso Por lo que representa el Salvador a
nivel geoestratégico y también por el
posicionamiento que tienen las maras o
las pandillas que no son únicamente una
problemática salvadoreña esto también se
ve en Guatemala en Honduras y en Estados
Unidos y pues ya también algunas partes
de México ya es prácticamente una
asociación de crimen transnacional quién
le asesora a este gobierno este tipo de
medidas quién puede estar detrás de esta
estrategia del presidente bukele para
sacar esto adelante Estados Unidos
comunidad internacional qué sé yo usted
me dirá
es difícil saberlo que hay que decir que
el presidente ha estado rodeado de
vendedores de asesores venezolanos
incluso de la del grupo de
guido
guaidó entonces han sido los asesores
incluso la
la estructura de funcionamiento del
gobierno prácticamente estos asesores
son los que estaban como dando la
directrices al ministerio incluso
entonces pero es difícil saberlo si
atrás hay una estructura Pero lo que sí
yo creo que en los últimos años hay toda
una corriente de articulación del de una
especie de populismo
que ha surgido en la región con varios
mandatarios con esta línea de posiciones
extremas que creo que de alguna manera
Hay una articulación y comparten
estrategias digamos por allí lo vería yo
más que no no veo que haya una
estructura
Un gobierno detrás pero si hay Aliado
verdad porque el tema de estas tipos de
de gobiernos populistas tiene sus
aliados en otros países que rican la
misma tipo de modelos claro Carlos algo
para decir sobre este tema y le añado y
le añado y le prolongo un poquito la
pregunta sobre este modelo exportable a
otros países muchos políticos están
mostrando muy interesados porque él
incluso ya salen en portadas de revistas
colombianas por ejemplo como por citar
solamente un caso Mire lo que usted dice
es muy importante y quiero citar un
estudio que se hizo monográfico para
optar por el título de magíster en
comunicación política en el externado
una serie de estudiantes hicieron un
ejercicio muy interesante en el cual
acompañamos todo el ejercicio de
publicación de trinos en Twitter de
nayib bukele antes de que fuese electo
dos meses antes de que fuera electo y
dos meses después de que fuera electo y
la palabra seguridad y todos los
palabras y emociones asociadas
seguridad autoridad fueron parte
constitutiva y el y fundamental de su
discurso esto básicamente lo mencionó
para señalar que todos los regímenes de
derecha del continente están viendo en
ese modelo narrativo en ese modelo de
exposición de show mediático una
alternativa para conseguir réditos a
corto plazo entre los ciudadanos y los
electores que en América Latina
lastimosamente uno de los temas más
frágiles en la seguridad y de esa manera
quiero empezar a responder ya Y cerrar
la pregunta el tema de la exportación
del modelo y de las alternativas y las
medidas que ha implementado buqueles son
altamente peligrosas en gobiernos con
altísima polarización como los que
estamos viviendo en América Latina
ejemplo de ello Colombia Argentina
Ecuador chile y Venezuela es decir todo
el continente todo el continente está
expuesto a una gran polarización y
cuando hay un gobernante que es exitoso
moviendo en exacerbar emociones en esa
polarización básicamente se convierte en
referente en el referente Eva algo para
decir sobre este tema
bueno lo único que quiero Añadir es que
bueno del lado de Estados Unidos y el
gobierno estadounidense ha visto
históricamente a El Salvador y Guatemala
y Honduras también como los exportadores
de migrantes Y eso crea un problema para
los Estados Unidos de de seguridad e
interés de su país y bueno de mi lado y
como yo lo veo es que los estados unidos
no ha sido tan vocal en cómo está viendo
el detrimento de los Derechos Humanos en
El Salvador Porque se ve que hay un
hay una baja tasa de migración en el
2022 por parte de de migrantes
salvadoreños entonces uno puede decir
Bueno si si no estoy atrayendo migrantes
porque
denunciarlos de una manera más vocal
Entonces sí es un problema que estamos
viendo Claro si está funcionando para
los intereses de un país Como por
ejemplo Estados Unidos en este caso pues
porque denunciarlo y porque decir que no
está funcionando vamos llegando a la
parte final de este programa y quiero
hablar y cerrar con lo que viene a
futuro y lo más inmediato son esas
elecciones presidenciales de febrero del
2024 prácticamente ya el país está en
etapa preelectoral qué tanto va a jugar
este tema de la seguridad de este
acierto que ha tenido Él en esta
política el presidente bukele en el tema
electoral cómo lo ve Abraham
Bueno yo creo que va a ser sobre todo la
carta de presentación que va a tener el
presidente bukele en la elección porque
es digamos A diferencia de otras
políticas como el bitcoin o con la misma
situación económica que que le ha
generado
digamos puntos negativos creo que el
punto digamos con el que puede presentar
el sistema de seguridad por eso está
nuestro juicio extendiendo el régimen ya
irracionalmente porque le sirve de de
eslogan político y publicitario pero por
el otro lado también hay que decir se
está cuidando y la asamblea legislativa
acaba de aprobar una reforma que permite
que ha cambiado una regla que existía
antes que en un plazo anterior a
elecciones no se podía haber cambios en
las reglas del juego y eso lo acaba de
modificar la asamblea legislativa por lo
tanto se pueden vislumbrar reformas para
asegurar digamos la correlación de
fuerza que pueda tener el gobierno y
creo que ese ya como posee un escenario
negativo Está tratando de cuidarse por
el lado de este tipo de reforma Eva su
opinión sobre este tema y también para
modo de cierre y conclusión
bueno siento que que este tema de
seguridad va a ser una así como dijo
Carlos Andrés Abraham una carta de
presentación va a ser el punto focal de
su plan de gobierno viendo hasta veinte
veintinueve porque lo va a vender como a
la va a vender a la población como Bueno
yo rindo resultados y si confían en mí
por los próximos cinco años voy a rendir
aún más resultados y hasta haciendo
problema más promesas tanto como bajar
los impuestos al cheque y hacer de El
Salvador un check hop Y sí Bueno sí
logró bajar las tasas de seguridad
quizás va a crear un check up de del
Salvador por cualquier medida posible
entonces va a ser un punto focal y Y sí
a ver por lo menos la atención
internacional y que la gente está
hablando del Salvador lo ha logrado
hacer en diferentes no solamente por el
tema de seguridad sino en otras áreas
Pero ha logrado llamar la atención por
parte de la comunidad internacional
Carlos para el cierre su conclusión y lo
que puede ser esto para para las
elecciones del 2024 mire Yo
lamentablemente veo un inminente ganador
yo no veo fácil y no veo ningún en este
momento ni siquiera hay un actor que
puede hacer la oposición un actor
político relevante con digamos con algún
tipo de incidencia electoral y de
participación política electoral en los
ciudadanos que estén en contra de nayib
bukele Yo pienso que tenemos un nuevo de
nuevo otro mandato de él y lo que más me
parece grave no es que él vaya a ganar
porque creo que es prácticamente lo
obvio a partir de la herramienta de
populismo que jugó yo lo que veo
lamentablemente es que hoy no se ha
construido una narrativa que le pueda a
él y a lo que él representa generar una
antítesis electoral Y si eso no se
despierta rápidamente en Salvador vamos
a tener bukele para rato o hasta que él
quiera salir del poder Pues con estas
palabras y con el análisis de nuestros
invitados finalizamos el programa de hoy
a Eva Abraham y a Carlos Andrés les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
un overview una vista panorámica lo que
está sucediendo en este país
centroamericano a raíz de el primer año
de haber sido puesto en marcha este
estado de excepción allí en el Salvador
es todo por hoy Les agradecemos su
sintonía En nombre del equipo técnico
les agradezco que hayan estado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y de
Giovanni agudelo la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]